ملياراته واسطوره العملات المشفره سان
بانك من فرايد هوت خلال شهر نوفمبر وتبخرت
كما تبخرت الامال بتحولها لنسخه التشفير
من عملاق القطاع المالي جون بيربونت
مورجان الذي اسس اكبر بنك امريكا
فرائسه بورصه العملات المشفره المنهاره اف
تي اكس الذي خسر نحو 15 مليار دولار في
يوم واحد اي نحو 94% من قيمه ثروته يهوي
هو الاخر في مستنقع الفوضى وفقا نيويورك
بوست صور متعدده نشرتها الصحيفه الامريكيه
تظهر ضياع الملياردير المفلس واصدقائه
تسعه في رفاهيه المنتجه الذي يمتلكه في
جزر المهامه ما بين ملاعب الجولف وليخوت
الفارهه حياته صاخبه بكل المقاييس احتيالا
ومخدرات واقامه حفلات بشكل دوري وما
يتضمنه ذلك من افعال فاضحه وفقا نيويورك
واضافت انا بانك من يتناول المخدرا يسمى
انسان وهو احد مشتقات المثل فيتامينات
المستخدم لعلاج مرضى الباركنسون لافته الى
معاناته من اثار الجانبيه جره تناولها هذا
المخدر
قيمه وصولهم خفضت الى صفر لتوصف حاله
بانكمن باحدى اكبر حوادث تدمير الثروه في
التاريخ وفقا لكن في ما سفينته تغرق يعيش
الشاب الفلسطيني في حاله انكار تام لما
يجري ولم يتوقف عن ممارسه العاب الفيديو
بحسب الصحيفه الامريكيه